la précédente séance a été distribué
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation et
en a t'il en séance je n'en vois point
le procès verbal est donc adoptée sous
les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
lambres du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise sur public
sénat sur notre site internet
chacun aura à coeur de respecter à la
fois son temps il se respecter les uns
les autres et je rappelle mais
maintenant c'est devenu un réflexe de
bien respecter à la fois les gestes
sanitaires et l'a sorti par l'arrière de
notre hémicycle à l'exception du
gouvernement qui sortira par le devant
de l'hémicycle
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
au gel préville pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
je vous donne ma parole ma chère
collègue merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
nous savons tous que quelque chose ne va
pas l'année 2020 a été l'une des plus
chaudes enregistrées
le réchauffement climatique est plus
rapide et plus intense que prévu
nous dansons littéralement sur un volcan
nous insistons aussi au lent déclin de
la biodiversité et sommes à l'aube du
sixième extinction
d'autre part les polluants continuent de
s'accumuler dans la nature notamment
avec le plastique véritable bombe à
retardement
les micro plastiques sont partout
envahissent l'air l'eau les sols et même
les tissus vivants
le drame c'est que nous sommes
responsables de ce qui nous arrive et
nous nous dirigions collectivement droit
dans le mur en effet nous avons fait si
peu et voir même tout le contraire
nous en sommes toujours à une logique de
ma voiture est plus grosse que la tienne
la consommation de vêtements a bondi de
40% en à peine 15 ans et la production
de plastique est exponentielle
les citoyens informés sont aujourd'hui
prêts à adhérer à des mesures
courageuses comme en témoignent les 150
membres de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
mérites de cette convention citoyenne de
montrer que les citoyens sont prêts à
relever le défi climatique
le changement climatique est une urgence
mondiale selon un sondage paru
aujourd'hui
organisé par le programme des nations
unies pour le développement
n'est-il pas temps d'adresser aux
français un discours de vérité
n'est-il pas temps de commencer à
réparer le monde n'est-il pas temps nez
de votre devoir de dire qu'une ville
comme nantes risquent d'être inondées
dans les prochaines années que toulouse
et tout fera sous les 45 degrés à
l'ombre l'été et que nos petits enfants
souffriront d'infertilité
si nous ne faisons rien il est urgent
d'éviter les catastrophes annoncées
ceux qui subiront les grands dommages de
notre inaction sont déjà nés et nous
leur devons de rebâtir un horizon commun
de civilisation notre politique est elle
à la hauteur pour relever un des défis
majeurs du siècle et la stratégie
nationale bas carbone est-elle la
feuille de route de tous les ministres
je vous remercie pour vous répondre
la parole est à notre dame des anges et
robin secrétaire d'état chargé de la
biodiversité madame la ministre et les
paroles merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénateure prévu effectivement la
feuille de route du président de la
république et du gouvernement est très
clair sur la transition écologique des
objectifs de sobriété de souveraineté de
solidarité et de soutenabilité dans
toutes les politiques que nous déployons
cette feuille de route elle doit faire
de la france une france résiliente une
france d'autres en carbone vous l'avait
dit et une france respectueuse de la
biodiversité
alors vous avez travaillé la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
qui s'est inscrite dans la loi énergie
climat qui nous donne cette ambition de
neutralité carbone en 2050 une réduction
de 20% de la consommation finale
d'énergie en 2030 par rapport à 2
12 33 % d'énergies renouvelables en 2030
une diminution de la part du nucléaire
dans la production à 50% 2021 sera
également l'année de la biodiversité
vous le savez avec des événements
nationaux et internationaux nous
réécrire l'ensemble de la stratégie
nationale biodiversité pour les dix
années à venir avec une stratégie qui va
partir des territoires et une écriture
qui se fera vraiment en lien avec les
départements les régions des élus les
acteurs et tous ceux qui doivent
participer à cette réécriture
nous avons un devoir de cohérence un
devoir de cohérence entre les moyens et
nos ambitions
ces moyens ils sont très clairement
réaffirmé dans le plan de relance avec
vous le savez un tiers des moyens dédiés
à la transition écologique
nous avons également cette volonté dans
la halle dans le cadre de nos mobilité
des moyens de transport nous avons
réécrit ses objectifs dans la loi
d'orientation des mobilités cette
politique elle s'incarne également dans
le cadre notre budget vert qui est le
premier de l' ocde c'est donc une
initiative exemplaire
cette politique ambitieuse de la portant
à bruxelles qu'il s'agisse de la finance
vers de la déforestation importé du
plastique que vous avez tout à fait
souligné à juste titre cette cohérence
entre nos ambitions et nos moyens nous
les déploieront et nous les affirmeront
leur de la cop15 biodiversité et de la
coop 26 pour le climat et la convention
citoyenne qui a travaillé à ces
questions et dont vous aurez à
travailler le texte de déploiement en
est la preuve
nous devons construire ces politiques et
je vous remercie de votre attention sur
ces questions la parole est maintenant
ghislaine pantel pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président à ma question
s'adresse au ministre des solidarités de
la santé monsieur le ministre la santé
ce ne sont pas que les hôpitaux et les
ehpad c'est aussi tout un secteur
médico-social qui interviennent en amont
et en aval des organes de santé plus
traditionnel et sont des infirmières des
aides-soignantes des aides à domicile ou
encore des accompagnements éducatifs et
sociaux qui s'estime aujourd'hui
déconsidérer déconsidérer car si le
segura permis de nombreuses avancées en
vue d'en consacrer le principe du lieu
de l'activité il a aussi ouvert une
profonde inégalité dans le monde et
santé social d'un côté les personnels
qui travaillent un hôpital ou en ehpad
et qui ont droit à la prime de l'autre
des soignants qui travailla maison
d'accueil spécialisée en foyer d'accueil
médicalisé où des aides à domicile qui
n'ont eu droit à rien chez moi en lozère
aux assiste à des situations ubuesques
où au sein d'une même association
certains salariés relevant du sanitaire
touchent la prime 1 tandis que ceux
relevant du médico social ne la touchent
pas de quoi alimenter la colère de
nombreux soignants dans le cas des aides
à domicile de cette absence de
reconnaissance est d'autant plus
regrettable qu'un nombre considérable de
nos aînés souhaitent être maintenus à
domicile et que beaucoup ne peuvent
assumer financièrement un placement en
maison de retraite
c'est d'autant plus insupportable
qu'elle exerce souvent les mêmes
missions que les personnels des pâtes
avec moins de matériel spécialisé et
donc des efforts physiques plus
importants concernant les aides à
domicile les organisations syndicales et
les employeurs sont bien parvenus à un
accord prévoyant une revalorisation de
15 % des salaires mais la commission
nationale d'agrément et les services de
l'état bloc de peur que les départements
de puisse assumer le financement
la conseillère départementale de la
lozère que je suis comprend la position
des départements qui font face à une
hausse de leurs dépenses sociales et qui
ne pourront assumer cette charge
il revient donc à l'état d'apporter une
solution à la matière car le risque à
terme c'est une fuite du personnel à
raison de trop bas salaires et des
fermetures d'établissements qui joue
pourtant un rôle majeur et évite bien
des hospitalisations
j'ai pris les indes des soignants et des
aide à domicile mais c'est bien tout un
pan du secteur médico-social qui a géré
cette crise et qui se sentent
aujourd'hui déconsidéré oui le fauteuil
au ministre par la classification
d'apporter par le ségur vous avez créé
deux catégories de soignants que comptez
vous faire pour mettre fin à cette
inégalité et permettre à l'ensemble du
monde deux soignantes de bénéficier de
cette prime
merci pour vos réponses de la parole et
hominidés solidarité de la chanter
chevron vous avez la parole madame la
sénatrice mortel merci pour votre
question qui me donne d'abord l'occasion
à nouveau de saluer l'action
déterminante de tous les acteurs du soin
du caire du bien prendre en charge les
personnes les plus fragiles parmi nos
concitoyens parmi lesquels évidemment
les salariés qui interviennent au
domicile dans le cadre d'activités
médico social mais également les aides à
domicile je vais essayer d'être plus
factuel possible
il ya deux catégories de questions dans
votre question celle qui porte sur ce
qu'on appelle les oubliés du ségur c'est
à dire tous ses salariés du soin dans le
secteur médico social
vous savez que nous avons demandé à
michel laforcade de réaliser une mission
pour pouvoir définir des périmètres de
revalorisation avec un engagement du
gouvernement qui est clair et depuis le
début en la matière il y aura une hausse
des revenus d'une toute une catégorie de
gens qui aujourd'hui sont effectivement
vous l'avez dit un peu de façon
aberrante travailler aux côtés de
soigner encore eu les revalorisations du
ségur alors que non pas c'est une
question de temps très court madame la
sénatrice je peux vous l'assurer
deuxième catégorie les aides à domicile
alors vous savez qui s'est passé
beaucoup de choses pour les à domicile
d'abord et la demande des élus de tous
bords il a eu cette prime coville qui a
pu être attribuées entre état et
département ce qui fait que en pratique
dans plus de 100 départements
c'est plus de 1000 euros de primes
qu'ovide qui ont pu être attribuées aux
aides à domicile j'en ai vu beaucoup
pendant la gestion de crise et pendant
le premier confinement croyez-moi f à
vous le savez c'est certainement pas
usurpée que de leur accorder cette prime
ensuite il ya le travaux le travail que
nous avons engagée sur la revalorisation
du point d'indicé dans la branche de
l'aide à domicile
il ya des négociations qui sont
réouvertes pour intégrer vous le savez
les 200 millions d'euros qui ont été
débloqués de façon pérenne dans la
nouvelle branche autonomie
complétez aux côtés des départements aux
côtés des départements la refonte de la
grille indiciaire de cette même branche
c'est un engagement absolument inédit
cette revalorisation de 200 millions
c'est un effort qui est justifié et je
n'ai aucun doute aucune interrogation en
considérant toute l'attention que porte
l'ensemble des élus aux aides à domicile
que nous parviendrons à un consensus un
accord le plus rapide possible
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant le point collègue sophie
taillé et poli ans pour le groupe
écologie solidarité territoire vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'économie et des finances
quand allez vous enfin lancée l'autre
campagne de vaccination que les français
attendent et réclame celle pour lutter
contre le virus des inégalités que le
rapport de l' ong oxfam a une fois de
plus mis en lumière
car l'un des remèdes à ce mal mondial
des inégalités qui n'épargne pas la
france on le connaît très bien il est
simple il s'appelle la justice fiscale
par un impôt juste et proportionnée un
impôt redistributif ciblées sur les plus
riches et en priorité sur les
ultra-riches et la france
par votre bilan se classe très mal sur
l' indicateur de mesure de la
progressivité de l'impôt elle est 47e
en septembre dernier on estimait à plus
de 50 milliards d'euros l'épargné
constituée par les français pendant le
confinement maintenant la chiffrent à
plus de 100 milliards d'euros
mais quand 10 % des français les plus
aisés mettait de côté 20 5 milliards
d'euros les plus modestes s'endettaient
et grossistes et les files d'attentes de
l'aide alimentaire
quand les 43 milliardaire français voyez
progresser leur fortune de 175 milliards
d'euros entre mars et décembre dernier
on constatait sur le territoire national
et nous sommes nombreux ici à l'avoir vu
une hausse de 8,5 pour cent des
demandeurs du rsa
la situation actuelle est le fruit de la
pandémie oui mais elle est aussi le
fruit de votre politique fiscale jamais
démenti depuis 2010 est alors
qu'attendez-vous maintenant face à la
situation d'urgence pour mettre en
oeuvre
les mesures propres à lutter contre les
effets ravageurs des inégalités bien
entendu augmenter l'aide aux plus
démunis
bien entendu augmenter les minima
sociaux mais bien entendu aussi revenir
sur la taxation des ultra riches
pourront répondre la parole et au
ministre délégué chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises monsieur grise et
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice
tailler polian le rapport oxame souligne
que la crise aggrave les inégalités en
montrant que les milliardaires ont
retrouvé leur niveau de richesse d'avant
crise et que dans le même temps la
pauvreté risque de progresser avec la
crise comme le montre le rapport
l'une des causes de la croissance du
patrimoine des milliardaires tient à la
politique de rachat d'actifs de la bce
qui a entraîné une hausse des cours
boursiers
mais c'est justement cette politique de
rachat d'actifs qui a permis et permet
encore aux états de s'endetter pour
mettre en oeuvre les mesures d'urgence
et notamment le soutien au pouvoir
d'achat des plus fragiles face à la
crise permettez moi de citer par exemple
les deux prime exceptionnelle créée en
2019 à destination des plus pauvres
le plan jeunes les soutiens budgétaires
aux étudiants le renforcement de l'aide
alimentaire et le renforcement de
l'hébergement d'urgence
les aides monétaires ont permis de
cibler en priorité les ménages les plus
précaires au regard des niveaux de vie
d'avant crise les deux tiers des ménages
bénéficiant de ces aides se situant dans
les 20% des plus modestes
le premier outil de lutte contre la
pauvreté
c'est le soutien à l'emploi c'est ce que
nous faisons avec le dispositif
d'activité partielle avec le fonds de
solidarité qui permet à des milliers de
centaines d'entreprises de se maintenir
je rappelle qu' un million neuf
d'entreprises ont bénéficié du fonds de
solidarité en 2020 et puis le plan un
jeune une solution cette politique
d'urgence à des résultats
l'insee prévoit une quasi stabilité du
revenu disponible brut des ménages en
moyenne soit l'année 2000
de façon plus structurelle notre système
fiscal et social est très redistributif
selon france stratégie du rapport de
décembre 2020 les inégalités de revenus
sont plus faibles en france que dans la
plupart de nos pays voisins
elles le sont encore plus après
redistribution grâce aux prestations
sociales est notre système fiscal
il serait en tout cas illusoire de
penser qu'une augmentation de la
fiscalité sur les ménages seraient
utiles l amélioration des comptes
publics
merci alain caillé po lyon quelques
secondes
merci monsieur le président quand
j'entends ministre dira que la pauvreté
risque de progresser je crois que là on
ne peut que constater le le le le fossé
terrible entre votre parole et la
réalité sociale et je suis vraiment
désolé monsieur grise est parce que la
justice fiscale elle touche autant les
pme que les ménages modestes et c'est
bien dommage que ce soit vous qui élit
répondu là dessus alors que vous le
savez en question de justice fiscale
eh bien il faudrait davantage aider les
petites et moyennes entreprises et
forcer les grandes entreprises à
respecter leurs devoir payer l'impôt la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
jean pierre decool pour le groupe les
indépendants république thierry peur de
la parole d'une crise à l'évolution
imprévisible
je me garderai bien de donner des leçons
encore moins de jouer au procureur dans
un pays où il serait si nombreux chaque
jour le gouvernement nous a preuve de
prévision et de chiffre tandis que les
scientifiques et les autorités
sanitaires alterne propos rassurants et
déclarations alarmistes quant aux
journalistes ils rapportent avec un
recul de quelques minutes
l'ensemble de ces informations
amplifiant la cacophonie générale on
ouvre puis on ferme des centres de
vaccination faute de dos en audition
vous dites 15 millions de personnes
seront vaccinées avant l'été la semaine
d'après 70 millions d'ici fin août étant
à peine 67 millions d'habitants trois
millions de français se ferait donc
vacciner deux fois
récemment les autorités envisager de
repousser la seconde injection de 3
semaines hypothèses désormais écarté en
vérité davantage que le réel retard ou
non de notre pays dans la mise en oeuvre
de la vaccination c'est l'absence de
clarté de votre communication qui
déconcerte et navre nos concitoyens
rapporteur fin 2018 d'une mission
sénatoriale sur la pénurie de
médicaments et de vaccins
je me sens moralement investi
monsieur le ministre oui ou non
disposons-nous d'un stock suffisant de
doses pour poursuivre lentement mais
résolument la vaccination déclenché mi
janvier
s'agit-il d'une pénurie de nature à
interrompre cette première vague de
vaccination si oui dans quel délai
prévoyez-vous la relance pour la
première injection
comme pour la seconde enfin la livraison
de vaccins seraient bloqués à cause de
problèmes de logistique
qu'en est il réellement ces questions
marqué d'angoise sont légitimes et un
apport un effort de transparence à
propos de vos difficultés permettrait en
toute humilité d'apaiser ce climat
anxiogène dont je me fais ici l'écho
pour répondre la parole
des solidarités de la chanter mes chiens
errants vous avez la parole monsieur le
sénateur de cool vous avez parfaitement
raison plus que jamais plus que jamais
dans notre pays nous avons besoin de
sérénité
nous avons besoin de précisions et nous
avons besoin de transparence
monsieur le sénateur je vais vous donner
quelques exemples 1
j'ai donné au public le la liste précise
des arrivages mois après mois de vaccins
nous permettant de vacciner mois après
mois un certain nombre de millions de
français tout en précisant bien que ces
chiffres correspondent tôt commandes qui
ont été passées par l'union européenne
et donc par la france et qu'ils
correspondent également à l'ensemble des
vaccins que nous avons achetés et donc
relevé aussi des décisions préalables
des autorités sanitaires et j'ai donc
effectivement expliqué que nous avions
jusqu'à de quoi potentiellement vacciner
70 millions de personnes d'ici à la fin
du mois d'août parce que nous avons plus
de 130 millions de doses qui sont
arrivés sur le territoire national à la
fin du mois d'août si tous les vaccins
sont homologués et si effectivement les
laboratoires respectent leurs
engagements et vous voyez comme moi mais
vous l'avez souligné vous même ce
problème logistique c'est qu'il ya déjà
des difficultés d'approvisionnement de
la part de certains laboratoires
nous faisons tout pour faire en sorte
que les laboratoires respectent leurs
engagements sinon effectivement ça
posera problème
ensuite monsieur le sénateur j'ai
répondu par exemple la semaine dernière
j'ai participé effectivement la
commission des lois et j'ai été
interrogé sur la nécessité de poursuivre
l'état d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 1er
juin
et la question qui m'a été posée est ce
que vous êtes sûr que d'ici au 1er juin
nous aurons vacciner tous les publics
fragiles j'ai pris le soin de répondre
oui regardez que le public fragile
potentiellement ça peut porter jusqu'à
23 à 30 millions de français et que
d'ici au début juin je ne sais pas si
nous aurons terminé de vacciner c'est à
dire fait deux injections certaines sont
distants de plusieurs semaines à 23 à 30
millions de français
ce qui n'empêche pas du tout par
ailleurs de compter sur les livraisons
de vaccins nous permettant d en vacciner
toute la population d'ici la fin du mois
d'août
encore une fois ce sont des sujets qui
sont complexes qui se font appel à des
chiffres à les vaccins à des données
scientifiques je sais que vous le savez
et je sais que vous comprenez parfois la
nécessité au delà de la transparence
d'expliquer les choses et pour ça il
faut un peu plus de tordu par exemple
vote les deux minutes se sont écoulées
j'aurai donc pas répondu à la totalité
de votre question simplement vous dire
monsieur le sénateur que je connais pas
ce que j'avais lu
le rapport vous aviez fait sur la
pénurie médicaments qui était un rapport
de grande qualité et sur lesquels nous
appuyons encore aujourd'hui pour prendre
certaines décisions
merci la parole j'ai à notre collègue
mathieu darnaud pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur monsieur le premier ministre
lors d'un récent déplacement dans le
grand test devant les élus de la
collectivité européenne d'alsace vous
avez déclaré ne pas avoir été convaincus
par les grandes régions
ajoutant à ces propos le fait d'être
prêt de revoir le transfert des
compétences en direction de cette
collectivité européenne d'alsace ces
propos qui nous interpelle traduit style
plus généralement une volonté du
gouvernement de revoir de remettre sur
la table
l'examen à l'examen par dont le
périmètre des grandes régions et par là
même la ventilation des compétences
entre les collectivités
au delà de ce sujet monsieur le premier
ministre nous voulons savoir où en est
le gouvernement sur l'une des réflexions
qui l'avait fléché comme prioritaires
sur les sujets aussi importants que ceux
de la décentralisation de la
déconcentration et de la différenciation
territoriales vous le comprenez c'est
pour nous des sujets ici au sénat
essentiels qui devait se traduire par
une loi
la fameuse loi 3d devenu loi cadre d or
aujourd'hui
voyant que peu à peu ce texte disparaît
des radars de nos travaux parlementaires
monsieur le ministre nous avons tout
simplement peur que le quatrième des
soit celui de la déprogrammation pour
nous répond la parole
la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur mathieu darnaud j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion hier à l'assemblée nationale
ne répondra la première partie de votre
question à savoir que quand il y a eu la
création de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace seul cissé fait dans un cadre
précis pas de démantèlement de la région
grand est et pas de collectivités à
statut particulier
c'est vrai que le premier minis qu'à
exprimer ce que vous avez rappelé sur le
découpage des grandes régions au fond il
a dit tout haut ce que beaucoup pensent
tout bas mais je tiens à mais je tiens à
préciser qu'il a dit également qu'il n'y
aurait pas de big bang territorial ce
que nous avons rappelé en permanence
depuis le début de ce mandat
quant à la deuxième question concernant
le projet de loi 4d d'abord je rappelle
que vous avez déjà voté ici en première
lecture
bien évidemment puisque c'est normal
qu'on passe au sénat d'abord c'est
constitutionnel le projet de loi
organique consacré à l'expérimentation
et donc à la différenciation et je vous
remercie d'ailleurs de la large majorité
qui a été votée à cette occasion par
ailleurs ce texte va passer
début mars à l'assemblée nationale
comme vous le savez le calendrier actuel
n'est pas encore complètement déterminé
trois shows je dirais premièrement on
passe en priorité tout ce qui concerne
la santé la lutte contre la crise de
covin ou de l'aco vide plus exactement
deuxièmement bien évidemment il y aura
un choix qui sa frappe qui sera fait
parce que le calendrier est extrêmement
chargé
mais troisièmement je dois vous dire que
je suis très contente et je vous en
remercie
si déjà du soutien que vous apportez à
la loi 4 d merci monsieur dardot
oui madame la ministre vous en
conviendrez nous attendrons de savoir ce
qu'il y a dans ce texte parce que nous
ce que nous avons pu voir ressemblent
plus à des petits matins cas un grand
soir de la décentralisation et de la
déconcentration
donc nous jugerons sur pièce nous
attendons de voir mais plutôt que de
partir sur de nouvelles pistes comme
celles qui ont été évoquées par le
premier ministre nous pensons qu'il est
temps de tenir plutôt que de courir je
vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue olivier
henno pour l'euro de l'union centriste
yeux le président mesdames messieurs les
ministres chaque collègue ma question
concerne plus la recherche et la
souveraineté que la stratégie vaccinale
proprement dit l'institut pasteur a
annoncé l'abandon de son projet de
vaccin ce renoncement est d'autant plus
douloureux que l'institut pasteur a
acquis au travers de son histoire une
réputation prestigieuse
c'est une deuxième déception française
après le retard du laboratoire sanofi
sans vouloir jouer les procureurs mot à
la mode
je veux rappeler il ya qu il y a
quelques mois le pdg de sanofi affirmé
avec arrogance que les américains
seraient servis les premiers
le voilà réduit du fait de l'urgence
sanitaire au rang de sous traitants de
ce double échec
nous pouvons tirer un constat évident il
n'y a pas de vaccin français
opérationnel alors que beaucoup d'autres
pays ont réussi à faire aboutir un ou
plusieurs de leurs projets comment
expliquer ce qu'il faut bien appeler une
étrange défaite de la recherche et de
l'industrie pharmaceutique française que
je taxerait d'étonnantes d'inquiétantes
et de révélatrice
plusieurs questions doivent être
abordées avec gravité pourquoi cette
erreur stratégique de nos laboratoires
d'avoir sous-estimé les biotechnologies
et particulièrement les arn messager
pourquoi ont-ils préféré la sécurité à
l'innovation
est ce la lourdeur de la réglementation
française qui s'avère pénalisante
est ce une question de moyens nous
disposons pourtant avec le crédit impôt
recherche d'un dispositif incitatif pour
les entreprises monsieur le ministre
quelle leçon et quelles conséquences
tirez-vous en termes de souveraineté et
de stratégie vaccinale à moyen et long
terme je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et mobilise
des solidarités de la santé monsieur
gérant monsieur le sénateur l'institut
pasteur
l'institut pasteur en france a été la
première structure scientifique a
séquencé le génome du virus coronavirus
en quelques jours faisant partager au
monde entier la séquence génétique du
virus
l'institut pasteur a abrité au moins
l'un des deux membres qui a d'ailleurs
découvert la rn message et en tant que
tel l'institut pasteur développe de très
nombreux projets de recherche
fondamentale recherche appliquée
recherche transverse en lien avec des
laboratoires du monde entier et
l'institut pasteur continue d'ailleurs
de développer des recherches sur des
médicaments qui pourraient être utiles
demain dans le cockpit mais également
des des vaccins c'est parce que un
projet de recherche n'aboutit pas à
celui sur le vaccin rougeole qu'il faut
considérer qu'il aurait failli à sa
mission et départs non de façon générale
ce que faisait aussi allusion une
intervention médiatique du président la
république faisons aussi l'éloge de
l'audace encourageant encourageons les
uns et les autres à entreprendre à
investir et à innover à rechercher si
rendez-vous cours de l'exploit qu'a
représenté la découverte non pas d'un
mais déjà de plusieurs vaccin contre un
virus inconnu il ya un an donc en moins
d'un an avec une force de production
mondiale qui capable de sortir 1,5
milliard de doses chercher dans
l'histoire contemporaine chercher dans
l'histoire lointaine un phénomène
équivalent une aventure scientifique
industrielle d'aussi grande portée à
l'échelle du monde et monsieur le
sénateur on peut regretter et ne veulent
pas pouvoir dire cocorico et de mettre
un drapeau bleu blanc rouge sur un
vaccin en tout cas pas aujourd'hui mais
soyons vigilants il ya encore des
travaux de recherche qui sont en cours
on peut au moins considérer que leur a
pas fait le travail
l'europe qui a commandé des vaccins pour
tous les pays européens l'europe qui
pense également aux pays du tiers-monde
qui n'ont pas forcément accès aux
vaccins et l'europe qui abrite nombre
d'entreprises dont la fameuse bayod
attaque on ne parle que de files heures
mais c'est by one tech avec des sites de
production en belgique en allemagne et
demain en france qui permet aujourd'hui
de protéger des centaines de millions de
personnes chaque jour en europe avec des
vaccins efficaces dont encourageant la
recherche encourageant les chercheurs et
surtout n'allons pas chercher des
responsabilités ni politique ni
scientifique
lorsqu'un projet n'aboutit pas un projet
de recherche de médicaments sur 100 à
bout
si et on considère que c'est déjà un bon
ratio en matière de recherche vaccinale
on est déjà bien au delà c'est une
chance pour l'humanité
monsieur hulot oui merci monsieur le
ministre vous nous dites qu'on peut
gagner les 24 heures du mans quand on a
raté son départ
il est vrai que ça arrive mais pour ça
il faut de l'humilité
il faut de la volonté et une stratégie
travail et adapté il me semble qu'ils
aient encore beaucoup à faire
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
notre collègue éric voter pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologie vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
mais quelle sauce adressée au ministre
de l'économie et des finances et de la
relance hallucinant vertigineux indécent
tels sont les termes qui pourraient
qualifier les constats faits par les ong
oxfam
dans son rapport annuel comme il le dit
si bien le monde est non seulement
confrontée aux coronavirus mais aussi
aux virus et inégalités un seul chiffre
monsieur le ministre
pour illustrer cette incroyable réalité
pour notre pays les milliardaires
français ont vu leur fortune s'accroître
de 175 milliards en 2020 c'est la
troisième plus forte progression au
monde
c'est aussi l'équivalent de deux fois le
budget de l'hôpital public dans ce pays
monsieur bernard arnault a même augmenté
sa fortune de 44 milliards d'euros entre
mars et décembre un bond de 41%
le lundi 25 janvier le jour même de la
publication de ce rapport monsieur le
président de la république déclarait
devant un parterre de dirigeants
d'entreprises étrangers je cite nous ne
ralentiront pas la réduction de l'impôt
sur les sociétés qui sera ramené à 25%
l'an prochain nous ne renoncerons pas à
la suppression de l' isf et nous
réduirons les impôts de production de 10
milliards d'euros par an fin de citation
nous en concluons donc que le
remboursement de la dette
ça sera pour tous les autres monsieur
ministe quand allez vous mettre à
contribution ceux qui ont de plus en
plus pour soutenir ceux qui ont de moins
en moins pour nous répondre
le ministre délégué chargé des petites
et moyennes entreprises
je suis à la grille et vous avez la
parole oui monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bouquet à
l'occasion de cette deuxième question
sur le rapport au sphinx aux femmes
pardon
permettez moi d'essayer de détailler mes
premiers propos depuis le début de ce
quinquennat le gouvernement a réduit
massivement les impôts sur les ménages
de 2018 et 2021 ce sont 22 milliards de
fiscalité que nous rendons aux ménages
nous n'avons pas oublié les ménages les
plus modestes le sénateur loin de là si
on regarde des situations individuelles
on voit que grâce aux différentes
mesures mises en place par ce
gouvernement en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat avec notamment la prime
d'activité ou le dégrèvement de la taxe
d'habitation
un couple locataire avec deux personnes
rémunérées au smic va bénéficier d'un
supplément de revenu de 272 euros par
mois lorsque lundi sione les mesures
fiscales prises depuis le début du
quinquennat et jusqu'à la crise
sanitaire
l'effet redistributif est largement
moindre sur les 20% des plus aisés que
sur les autres ménages de l'ordre de
deux fois et demie notre politique
fiscale a démontré son efficacité avant
la crise nous avions reconstruit notre
compétitivité enrayer l'exil fiscal et
nous avons accéléré le retour en france
de contribuables lac attribution
exceptionnelle sur les hauts revenus
permet de faire contribuer de manière
spécifique les foyers les plus aisés aux
charges publiques
le gouvernement n'envisage pas
d'augmenter le taux de contribution
exceptionnelle sur les hauts revenus
notre politique c'est de baisser les
impôts pas de les augmenter pour
quiconque
cela est plus vrai dans le contexte
actuel qui appelle à des mesures de
soutien et de relance
une augmentation poserait notamment à
priori un problème constitutionnel
additionnée à l'impôt sur le revenu au
taux maximal de 45 % et aux prélèvements
sociaux de 17,2 une augmentation du taux
aboutirait à une taxation globale qui
pourrait être considéré comme
confiscatoire par le conseil
constitutionnel
ainsi je peux vous éléments vous
répondre que ce gouvernement a été au
rendez vous pour améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat de l'ensemble des français tout
en protégeant les plus vulnérables
monsieur bloqués y at il quelqu'un à
bercy pour s'occuper des milliardaires
hier au sommet virtuel de davos le
président de la république déclarait
ceci on ne sortira pas de cette crise
sans combattre les inégalités et bien
passer aux actes
rétablissez un isf renforcée taxer les
dividendes augmenter le taux de la
taxation des transactions financières
aujourd'hui à 0 3% et combattait
résolument l'évasion fiscale qui nous
coûte des dizaines de milliards d'euros
chaque année
merci la parole est à notre collègue
richard yung dans leur groupe du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant le la
parole monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question porte sur les
relations transatlantiques et plus
particulièrement sur celle entre la
france et les états unis
nous avons été nombreux à saluer
l'arrivée de joe biden à la maison
blanche le 20 janvier
donald trump par ses excès sa
méconnaissance des enjeux géopolitiques
sont des intérêts aussi peut-être ainsi
que par son agressivité à exacerber
suscité des tensions entre l'europe et
les états unis
il y aurait bien sûr de nombreuses
autres questions a évoqué s'agissant des
etats-unis l'iran la palestine etc
mais on ne peut pas tout couvrir certes
certaines divergences stratégiques et
est antérieure à la présidence trump
mais durant ces quatre dernières années
à notre grand regret la relation
transatlantique s'est effrité le 46e
président des états unis semble lui très
attaché au multilatéralisme et veut
rétablir un dialogue fort avec ses
alliés européens et là notamment
envoyer des signaux forts dès le début
de son mandat
en renouant l'accord de paris sur le
climat avec les premiers échanges entre
le président macron et son homologue
américain sur ceux ci ont permis de
dessiner des points de convergence c'est
positif car une alliance transatlantique
forte contribuera au dénouement d'un
certain nombre de dossiers multilatéraux
nous nous inquiétons toutefois des
points de tensions apparues au cours du
mandat de son prédécesseur qui ne vont
pas disparaître du jour au lendemain
tels les tendances protectionnistes la
législation sur les géants du numérique
la taxe carbone ou le fait d'imposer la
législation américaine partout dans le
monde
pourtant nous en sommes convaincus il
est nécessaire que les états unis et
l'europe salies sur le plan commercial
monsieur le ministre quelles initiatives
la france pourra-t-elle portée pour
rétablir les relations normales avec les
états unis et plus largement quelles
visions voulez vous pour la france dans
le choix des coopérations prioritaires à
mettre en oeuvre
quels premiers sujets seront inscrits
sur votre agenda
on vous répondre la parole et ambitieux
du lit de leur fait les affaires
étrangères monsieur landry monsieur le
sénateur richard yom vous l'avez rappelé
il s'agit d'un nouveau chapitre de la
relation transatlantique qui vient de
s'ouvrir
le président de la république s'est
entretenu avec le président bailly donne
longuement dimanche dernier moi même je
re l'occasion tout à l'heure de
m'entretenir avec mon nouveau collègue
anthony blinken qui lui-même vient
d'être confirmée par le sénat
hier soir royer qui sera vite nous nous
constatons que les premiers gestes de
l'administration américaine sont des
gestes qui marque un retour des états
unis au multilatéralisme vous avez cité
l'accord de paris mais c'est le retour
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
c
la volonté de revenir dans les accords
de vienne sur le nucléaire iranien
c'est aussi un fait qui je crois
beaucoup échappé mais l'accord avec le
président poutine sur la prolongation du
traité new star pour cinq ans permettant
la maîtrise des armements nucléaires
stratégiques c'est une nouvelle très
importante et c'est fait
donc nous devons construire sur cette
nouvelle base et nous avons essayé de le
faire aussi dans le domaine économique
vous avez cité les exemples il faut
mettre fin à l' escalade tarifaires et
revenir à une négociation négocier de
nos différends commerciaux qui existent
il faut les gérer dans le cadre de l'om
c'est dans le cadre d'une négociation
comme il faut parvenir à un compromis
sur la régulation des plateformes
numériques et notamment sur la fiscalité
de leur activité nous y travaillons et
nous allons y travailler sur le sujet
que j'aborderai tout à l'heure avec
monsieur blinken j'aurais voulu surtout
qu' il n'y a pas eu une parenthèse
depuis quatre ans depuis quatre ans le
monde a changé mais l'europe a changé
nous sommes sur une nouvelle donne
l'europe n'est plus la même et donc nous
devons continuer de construire une
europe forte et souveraine car c'est la
condition d'une alliance transatlantique
et d'une otan rééquilibrer et refonder
au mieux de nos intérêts respectifs qui
nous faut respecter les uns et des
autres merci merci je subisse la parole
d'un autre collègue alain larcher pour
le groupe est républicain
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur bruno le maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
vous lui transmettrai il y a quelques
jours vous vous êtes opposé au
rapprochement entre le groupe canadien
couche tard est le groupe carrefour
au nom de la sécurité et de la
souveraineté alimentaire si l'intention
est bonne car la crise que nous
traversons révèle la perte de notre
souveraineté économique
nous avons la désagréable impression que
ce choix et surtout guidée par des
intérêts politiciens plutôt que par la
volonté réelle de protéger les intérêts
de la france
carrefour c'est l'arbre qui cache la
forêt de vaud paradoxe car comment
expliquer que vous affichez une fermeté
sans faille au sujet de carrefour alors
qu'en parallèle l'europe signe un nouvel
accord d'ouverture des marchés avec la
chine qui n'assure pas les conditions
d'une concurrence équitable car comment
invoquer la larme à l'oeil
la souveraineté alimentaire et en même
temps empêcher le sénat de se prononcer
sur la ratification du c'est à ce traité
qui ouvre nos frontières aux produits
des fermes usines du canada et qui
engendre des conséquences désastreuses
pour une partie de notre production
agricole nationale
nous sommes nombreux à ne pas percevoir
la rationalité de ses pensées très
complexe
monsieur le ministre et pourtant c'est
un vrai sujet souveraineté alimentaire
qui dépasse de loin le rachat d'un
distributeur
cela fait 18 mois que le sénat à temps
de se prononcer sur le ceta mais
contrairement à d'autres textes comme le
projet de loi bioéthique qui nous sont
imposés à marche forcée il semble s'être
perdu sur le chemin de la navette
parlementaire
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
expliquer à quelle logique vous obéissez
quand allez vous interrogez le sénat sur
le ceta
[Applaudissements]
on répondra par le sous ministre délégué
chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises
le chu crise est bien madame la
sénatrice chercher comme l'a indiqué
bruno le maire la semaine dernière je
vous confirme ne fait que nous
considérons que le rôle de l'état est de
protéger et de veiller à la défense des
secteurs stratégiques de la nation
la crise sanitaire nous montrent que la
sécurité alimentaire des français est un
enjeu stratégique
nous devons distinguer l'état
actionnaire de l'état régulateur
l'état n'a pas vocation être actionnaire
d'entreprises dans des secteurs autres
que l'énergie nucléaire les transports à
la défense comme indiqué bruno le maire
l'état a un rôle de régulation de
l'économie afin de définir des règles
économiques et défendre l'intérêt
général
notre devoir est donc de protéger les
entreprises qui engagent la sécurité du
pays et des français et cela ne va pas à
l'encontre de la ratification du sénat
bien au contraire par ailleurs nous ne
vont pas confondre attractivité et le
fait de des fous de vendre au plus
offrant le premier employeur du pays
l'attractivité consiste à faire venir
enfants des investisseurs étrangers qui
participent à la création de valeur et
d'emplois accroître l'intégrité de la
france passe par la simplification et la
fiscalité
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis 2017 et
la réforme en porter leurs fruits
je peut notamment citer quelques
exemples d'investissements canadien en
france le canada figure à la 10e place
des investisseurs étrangers en france à
la quatrième pour les investisseurs des
pays européens à la suite du rachat
bombardier transport par alstom à la
star mourad par ailleurs pour premier
actionnaire la caisse des dépôt et
placement du québec qui est aussi
actionnaire aux côtés de la sncf et de
keolis
vous l'aurez compris madame la sénatrice
l'état régulateur n'empêche absolument
pas la ratification du sénat
avec un peu de patience on y arrive
tandis que l'état protecteur doit être à
même de protéger ses entreprises et
citoyens s'agissant de la sécurité
alimentaire
nous sommes habitués aucune réponse à la
question mais malgré tout votre réponse
conforte ma première impression le refus
du rachat de carrefour est un écran de
fumée
un coup de communication facile qui
accompagne en pleine crise la sortie du
livre du ministre des finances
si vous voulez protéger la souveraineté
alimentaire de la france laisser nos
entreprises décidé de leur alliance et
laisser le sénat a donné son avis sur le
ceta merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant de sa collègue
monique lubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
merci sur présidente la parade
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture
je vais vous parler monsieur le ministre
vous le savez de la crise est lié à
l'influencé aviaire qui frappe le
département des landes mais aussi le
département du gers
j'associerai d'ailleurs à mon propos mes
collègues éric kerrouche et franck
montaugé
vous êtes venu et vous avez vu vous
connaissez parfaitement la situation
je donnerai néanmoins quelques chiffres
afin que chacun mesure ici l'ampleur du
phénomène les filières palmipèdes à foie
gras et volaille maigre ce sont plus
d'un millier d'exploitations 7300
emplois directs production et
transformation et puis de 20000 emplois
au total en comptant les emplois induits
c'est le deuxième pôle économique de
notre département pour un chiffre
d'affaires de 438 millions d'euros à ce
jour ce sont deux millions de bêtes qui
ont été abattus je vous laisse imaginer
la désespérance dans nos campagnes
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre passé
les questions relatives aux opérations
de dépeuplement et d'indemnisation des
bêtes abattues se posent les questions
de l'avenir
les producteurs vont connaître plusieurs
mois d'inactivité
le représentant de l'état nous a dit que
le principe des indemnisations liées
vide sanitaire était acté pouvez vous
nous en donner le calendrier et les
modalités et nous confirmer que cela
concernera tous les producteurs y
compris ceux qui subissent les dégâts
collatéraux
même question pour les entreprises de
transformation monsieur le ministre de
plus pourront-elles bénéficier de la
prise en charge au titre du chômage
partiel
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui enfin
monsieur le ministre vous savez que se
côtoient différents modèles de
production
nous sommes très attachés à la
production de plein air c'est l'adn de
notre département de celui du gers ou de
celui des départements voisins et c'est
ce qui porte toute la filière par quels
moyens allez vous soutenir tous les
acteurs de la filière afin qu'ils
trouvent les modalités de la poursuite
de leur activité sans avoir à subir tous
les ans les conséquences de ces épisodes
sachant qu'il faudra éviter les
solutions simplistes telles que la
claustration systématique et néanmoins
ne fermer aucune fenêtre de réflexions
telles que celle de la vaccination et de
l'alimentation monsieur julien de
normandie vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice monique lubin la situation à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés est un
épisode très sérieux vraiment très
sérieux d'influenza aviaire
vous l'avez dit nous étions ensemble
dans les landes je voudrais d'ailleurs
saluer votre action c'est lui également
l'action de de votre collègue montaugé
et de votre collègue qui rouge on était
tous ensemble dans les landes ou dans le
gers pour être aux côtés des éleveurs et
je veux d'abord commencé mes propos en
disant de manière très solennelle que
l'ensemble des représentants ici au
sénat ou à l'assemblée et au
gouvernement se tiennent à côté des
éleveurs dans cet épisode à nouveau
dramatique que vit la filière qu'est ce
que nous devons faire d'abord
malheureusement nous n'avons d'autre
choix que de procéder à ces dépeuplement
vous l'avez dit près de deux millions de
canards ou de vous
hayes ont été abattus ce qui permet de
contenir au maximum cette influente sa
aviaire première chose deuxième chose
pour répondre à votre question oui nous
allons mettre en place et indemnisations
et les indemnisations au titre du
dépeuplement arrive dès maintenant parce
que j'ai souhaité que ce soit par un
système d'acomptes et pas par un système
d'évaluation a posteriori comme nous en
avons tenté tant l'habitude qui faisait
que parfois cette indemnisation pour des
peuplements arrivé six mois après donc
les premières indemnisations arrive dès
maintenant dans les lands a par exemple
déjà commencé deuxième troisième élément
de réponse
ces indemnisations ça c'est pour le
dépeuplement ensuite on va travailler
pour savoir les pertes d'exploitation
comme l'avouent comme vous l'avez dit
pour les éleveurs mais aussi pour les
entreprises impactées répondant ainsi
très clairement votre question ça
nécessite vous le savez un travaille
également au niveau européen sur ces
êtres dits d aide commerciale des aides
de marché enfin troisième élément de
réponse oui il y à la question de la
presse qui sera posée moi je vais avoir
une approche très pragmatique
c'est à dire de se demander qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans les mesures
de biosécurité et comment les renforcer
sans pour autant revenir sur les modèles
je crois par exemple au modèle du plein
air la question n'est pas le modèle la
question sont les mesures de biosécurité
et évidemment je vous disais je vous y
associerez merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
marie pier richer pour le groupe l'est
républicain et son président monsieur
ministre je veux vous alerter sur la
situation très préoccupante de ce qu'on
peut qualifier de désertification
pharmaceutique qui touche l'ensemble des
officines mais plus particulièrement
celle de nos territoires ruraux
ce phénomène qui accompagne la
désertification médicale aggrave le
problème de l'accès aux soins de leurs
habitants notamment les plus âgés qui de
ce fait peuvent éprouver davantage de
difficultés pour rester à leur domicile
alors que la politique des pouvoirs
publics visent à ligny maintenir le plus
longtemps possible pour y remédier
plusieurs dispositifs sont prévues qui
malheureusement ne répondent pas à
l'urgence de la situation
que ce soit les dispositions envisagées
dans le cadre du décret territoires
fragiles qui autoriserait l'ouverture
d'une officine dans une commune située
dans un territoire reconnu comme tel ou
du dispositif permettant la réouverture
d'une officine dans une commune qui en
disposait dans le passé or dans ces deux
cas il ne s'agit que de transfert de
licence non de création d'officine et
surtout ces dispositions ne vis que des
communes dans des situations bien
spécifique ce qui ne règle pas la
situation de la plupart des petites
communes rurales les plus nombreuses et
les plus exposées à ce phénomène
de son côté l'article 95 la loi zappé
envisage la possibilité d'autoriser
l'installation d'antennes de pharmacie
rattaché à une pharmacie de proximité
dans le cas où la seule officines du
village c'est son activité sans avoir
trouvé de repreneur
cette mesure que je salue pourrait
prendre la forme de pharmacie merfy
comme je vous l'avais proposé dans une
question écrite du 23 juillet dernier
resté à ce jour sans réponse toutefois
elle pourrait s'étaler sur plusieurs
années pour aboutir dans le meilleur des
cas un système qui ne serait que
provisoire
il reste soumis à sa mise en place par
les ars au risque de disparités
territoriales manifeste c'est pourquoi
monsieur le ministre j'aimerais
connaître les mesures concrètes que vous
entendez preuves dans les meilleurs
délais pour mettre fin à cette véritable
hémorragie de ses praticiens de santé
que sont les pharmaciens qui en cette
période de pandémie ont encore montré le
rhône et la place indispensable qu'ils
occupent dans nos territoires au service
de nos concitoyens
je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à au
ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur verrons merci madame la
sénatrice pour votre question orale je
regarderai je vous le promets l'autre
question écrite n'en recevons beaucoup
et dans la période et on traiter toutes
les questions
c'est pas une excuse vous êtes je suis
d'accord avec vous je crois avoir signé
pas moins de dix-huit courriers à
destination de sénateurs avant de vous
rejoindre tout à l'heure et je le fais
chaque semaine votre question écrite
sera donc une réponse je lis ça sous le
regard vigilant de notre ministre en
charge des relations avec le parlement
marc fesneau qui est très attentif à ce
que les ministres répondent aux
parlementaires il a raison madame la
sénatrice sur cette question de
l'organisation des pharmacies dans
territoire d'abord vous avez raison de
souligner l'importance du bailliage
pharmaceutique dans notre pays il est
précieux et on l'a vu d'ailleurs pour la
distribution des masques la réalisation
des tests antigénique et demain je
l'espère je le souhaite
la distribution de vaccins voir la
vaccination les pharmaciens ou une place
de plus en plus importante dans notre
système de santé
ils s'en réjouissent et je m'en réjouis
car ça faisait un certain nombre
d'années qu'il y avait un travail qui a
été fait une réflexion conduite sur
l'évolution du métier de pharmacien
c'est parfois madame la sénatrice au
fond et ça rejoint la réponse que je
vais vous donner c'est parfois le
dernière offreurs de soins dans une
commune donnée est effectivement à
mesure qu'on regroupe des médecins en
maison de santé pluriprofessionnelle à
l'échelle non pas des communes et des
intercommunalités se son territoire
urbain au graal d'ailleurs vous avez un
certain nombre de cabinets médicaux qui
ferme qui auparavant jouxtait une
pharmacie qui se retrouve donc sans
médecin prescripteur à proximité raison
pour laquelle nous travaillons ardemment
par exemple avec le réseau des cps pour
retisser du lien et des partenariats
raison pour laquelle nous avons voté il
y as je crois que vous l'avez voté aussi
il y a deux ans la possibilité d'avoir
des prescriptions dérogatoire par des
pharmaciens dans des cadres proto
colisée bref pour conférer aux
pharmaciens un rôle toujours plus
important d'offrir de soin à part
entière dans notre système de santé et
ainsi conforter leur installation après
il ya toutes les questions des
dérogations
j'ai aussi beaucoup saisie comme
ministre sur les dérogations des
pharmacies qui peuvent pas s'installer
constat faut savoir que quand il ya trop
de pharmacie dans un endroit
et bien c'est l'ensemble des pharmacies
qui en pâtit quand un médecin qui part
et qui regroupait
la pharmacie qui en pâtit et en
définitive c'est moins d'ailleurs les
pharmacies dans les territoires ruraux
qui sont parfois en difficulté que des
pharmacies dans des grands quartiers
urbains lorsque vous avez un très grand
groupe qui s'installe qui rachète
plusieurs pharmacies et qui fait une
espèce de super officines je ne suis pas
à titre personnel très favorable je
crois vraiment à la proximité la
pharmacie de quartier avec un pharmacien
qui connaît bien les patients qui
viennent le voir et vous pouvez croire
en un engagement pour pouvoir le
conforter dans la durée même riche et
une pharmacie une pharmacie ferme tous
les deux jours sur le territoire
national soit 200 par an
ce n'est plus de l'actualité c'est de
l'urgence et nous ne pourrons pas dire
que nous ne savions pas n'attendons pas
que la désertification pharmaceutique
s'installe et qu'on la laisse venir
comme la désertification médicale
[Applaudissements]
la parole est
le pr collègues nadia sur le groupe pour
le groupe de l'union centriste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues les agriculteurs attendaient
avec impatience ce 20 janvier
l'instruction des dossiers
départementaux de reconnaissance des
calamités agricoles suite à la
sécheresse de 2020 la réunion vient tout
être reportée d'un mois
monsieur le ministre les paysans sont en
colère ils le sont d'autant plus que
l'administration semble avoir changé les
règles de calcul des pertes
d'exploitation et la prise en compte des
années de référence la terrible crise
sanitaire que nous traversons ne doit
pas nous faire oublier que la france
qu'on est également pour l'ensemble de
ces filières une grave crise agricole
c'est un immense plan social que connaît
notre agriculture pour exemple deux
mille éleveurs bovins disparaissent
chaque année des productions
d'excellence française sent menacé dans
ce contexte les agriculteurs épuisé et
découragé n'accepte pas qu'on les achève
avec des contingences bureaucratique
administrative avec des réunions différé
avec des règles de calcul qui change
avec des normes avec des règlements et
des doctrines ils vont descendre dans la
rue car ils ont un besoin urgent et
vital de l'indemnisation des calamités
agricoles loyalement monsieur ministre
après les espoirs déçus de la loi et
galim alors que les inquiétudes
concernant le ceta subsistent qui se
sentent lâchés et lynché avez vous la
volonté que l'instruction des dossiers
de calamités agricoles se tiennent de
toute urgence sans en changer les règles
pour vous répondre la parole et mobilise
l'agriculture l'alimentation celle de
normandie
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice
je suis désolé mais je peux pas vous
laisser dire de tels propos sur notre
action
je crois que j'ai pu a démontré à quel
point on fait preuve parfois de beaucoup
de courage politique pour aider notre
monde agricole auquel on est tenté tant
et tant attaché alors aujourd'hui on a
un certain nombre de défis et la mère
des batailles et là je laisse mon habit
de ministre de l'agriculture je prends
celui de l'ingénieur agronome la mère
des batailles c'est la question de l'eau
est trop souvent de
puis des années des années on a mis sous
le tapis cette question de l'eau et on
s'est tous perdus dans d'autres sujets
s'agissant du monde agricole alors que
la principale question c'était la
question de l'eau sauf que depuis que
l'homme est sédentaire
dès qu'on parle de gestion de l'eau
c'est à chaque fois une question de
conflits de lui peut-être le sujet sous
le tapis ben moi je veux pas mettre le
sujet sous le tapis et je ne le ferai
pas premièrement ça veut dire quoi
premièrement c'est que quand il ya ces
épisodes de sécheresses et autres
oui il faut un des mini indemnisés il
s'avère qu'on a tellement de cas
tellement de cas que le comité il s'est
bien tenue il s'est tenu en janvier mais
il y avait tellement de cas qu'on a dû
faire deux comités 1 en janvier
et le prochain en février il y aura le
département de la nièvre ça montre en
quoi ça montre que c'est plus
occasionnels que c'est récurrent c'est
ça la réalité mais c'est pas une
lourdeur administrative
il ya des hommes des femmes qui se
battent pour les agriculteurs alors
arrêtons cette administration de bashing
c'est insupportable c'est des gens qui
bossent pour nos agriculteurs deuxième
élément au delà de ces indemnisations
il faut prendre le problème à la racine
donc 1 il faut développer les retenues
d'eau c'est difficile c'est compliqué
c'est du courage politique et je vais
vous dire c'est du courage politique
nationale et locale et vous le savez
bien parce que y'en a combien qui vont
manifester ensuite sur les les retenues
d'eau ici ou là en en faisant des des
éléments de campagne électorale c'est
insupportable c'est difficile il faut le
faire dans la concertation mais faut le
faire et des derniers éléments il faut
accompagner nos agriculteurs et dans le
plan de relance on met mine de 100
millions d'euros pour aider nos
agriculteurs à investir
on fait cela avec une volonté forte à
chaque fois n'oublions jamais de revenir
à la racine des problèmes est la racine
des problèmes c'est la question de l'eau
donc on va le faire et on le fera avec
force et courage et avec vous
[Musique]
madame sur le rouge
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie je
partage totalement votre conviction je
siège au comité national de l'eau et je
travaille à tous les sujets mais je vous
parle de trésorerie je sais que dans le
plan de relance ya des lignes de crédit
d'investissement je vous parle de
trésorerie dont ils ont besoin de façon
urgente si la moitié des dossiers ont
été instruits
alors dites moi pourquoi ils sont
inquiets sur le changement éventuel des
règles du jeu voilà j'entends aussi ce
qui ce qui me font augmenter
donc voilà ils ont besoin de façon
urgente de trésorerie nous avons besoin
tous ensemble de travailler à la gestion
de l'eau certaines de leurs demandes
sont également difficiles à traiter en
ce qui concerne la gestion de l'eau ils
ont d'autres heureux demande de ce côté
et voilà il faut vraiment vraiment là il
ya un sujet très urgent sur la table et
je vous remercie de comprendre l'urgence
du dossier
merci la parole et l autre collègue
martin berthet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre je souhaite vous
alerter sur la situation des communes de
montagne et plus largement des communes
touristiques
la fermeture prolongée des remontées
mécaniques je tiens à vous le redire
n'impacte pas seulement les entreprises
liées aux sports d'hiver c'est tout un
écosystème qui s'écroule et les finances
des communes avec la saison 2020-2021 ne
sera pas blanche malgré la neige
abondante mais bien noir au delà ce sont
toutes les communes touristiques de
notre pays qui sont impactés par cette
crise l'effondrement de leurs recettes
particulières comme celle des remontées
mécaniques taxe affermage régies y
compris pour les départements comme la
taxe de séjour ou celles tirées de la
présence d'un casino mais aussi de leurs
loyers locatifs de leurs recettes de
stationnement etc
les met d'ores et déjà en grande
difficulté pour leurs budgets de
fonctionnement et obère toute capacité
d'investissement si le sénat a été en
partie entendue avec la reconduction du
filet de sécurité pour le bloc communal
cela reste insuffisant dans ce mécanisme
destiné à limiter la casse les recettes
des régies municipales ont été exclus
par le gouvernement par ailleurs la
prise en compte des baisses de recettes
agrégé en un panier global entraîne des
sous-évaluations importante
un exemple d'une commune qui pour un
million d'euros de pertes en 2020 n'a
reçu jusque là que 215 milles euros
d'indemnisation
la conséquence de ces moindre ressource
pour tous sera un engrenage infernal
avec moins d'investissements et de
travaux privés et publics donc moins
d'emplois aussi monsieur le premier
ministre pour ces collectivités de zones
touristiques que les dispositifs de
péréquation classe souvent parmi les
plus riches ne pensez vous pas qu'il
serait opportun à côté de mesures de
soutien plus forte de leur faire
confiance de les exonérer de leur
participation au dispositif de
péréquation et de leur permettre
d'investir le montant dans la relance de
l'activité économique de leur territoire
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
madame jacqueline gourault merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice verte et je comprends votre
émotion bien sûr en tant que sénatrice
de la savoie et nous savons tous que la
montagne est mise à rude épreuve cette
année avec bien sûr ce que vous avez
rappelé la baisse des taxes payées par
les vacanciers bien sûr les pertes de
recettes des remontées mécaniques
vous l'avez rappelé aussi plusieurs
mesures ont déjà été prises par l'état
bien sûr le filet de sécurité sur les
recettes fiscales et domaniale qui vaut
en 2020 mais aussi comme vous le savez
en 2021 puisque ça a été votée dans le
budget est bien évidemment la taxe de
séjour et la taxe sur les remontées
mécaniques sont intégrés à la
compensation
je le précise les syndicats qui
perçoivent seulement de la taxe sur les
remontées mécaniques ont été intégrés
sur proposition du parlement
enfin la taxe de séjour est prise en
compte sur le seul exercice 2010 neuf
non pas par rapport à la moyenne 2017
2019 ce qui favorise les communes
touristiques
par ailleurs il existe des aides plus
sectorielles les salariés des régies
autonome de remontées mécaniques et des
domaines skiables sont éligibles à
l'activité partielle depuis une
ordonnance du mois de mars
ceux des régies thermale le sont aussi
depuis décembre le gouvernement s'est
engagé à compenser les pertes
d'activités des expressions de d
exploitation de remontées mécaniques
même madame si celles ci sont gérés
en régie dans les mêmes conditions que
le privé le dispositif est en cours de
finalisation
enfin vous m'interrogez sur le pic vous
savez madame d'abord que les taxes liées
à l'activité touristique ne sont pas
intégrés dans le flic et le pic c'est
toujours la même chose si vous prenez à
certaines communes ou si vous supprimez
le spica certaines communes
évidemment c'est les plus pauvres il y
en a aussi dans les zones de montagne
qui on touche moi la parole et vatan
notre collègue jean yves le conte pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine
le feu le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le ministre depuis deux ans un
pays la guinée est prise en otage par la
volonté de son président de s'offrir un
troisième mandat en 2020 plus de 250
personnes ont trouvé la mort dans des
violences politiques
des centaines ont été raflés et placé en
détention pendant ce temps quelques
rapaces gagne les richesses du pays gage
les richesses du pays principalement la
bauxite exploités comme jamais sans
bénéfice pour la population bien au
contraire très réservé sur le processus
électoral la cedeao et l'union africaine
ont pesé au printemps pour un report des
élections législatives et du référendum
constitutionnel
elles ont appelé à l'apaisement et au
dialogue la trajectoire du locataire de
sékoutoureya monsieur alpha condé
n'apportant pas varié le 18 octobre se
sont tenues les élections
présidentielles des centaines de
personnes dont les responsables de
l'opposition chérif bah ousmane gaoual
diallo qui ont documenté des fraudes
avérées lors du scrutin sont aujourd'hui
incarcérés
ces derniers ont mis plus d'un mois pour
avoir accès à un juge leur avocat
français n'ont pas accès à eux en prison
entre répression et prédation les jeunes
de guinée ne voit pas la vie d'avenir
pour eux dans leur pays la guinée était
récemment le quatrième pays d'origine
des demandeurs d'asile en france est le
premier pays d'origine des enfants
étrangers non accompagnés
en outre depuis le début et la fin du
second mandat d'alpha condé les départs
ont augmenté de plus de 300% la
situation actuelle pourrait s'avérer
désastreuse contenu de la résolution de
la jeunesse a quitté ce cauchemar nous
avons noté dans l'interview donnée par
le président de la république m
un jeune afrique la dureté de ses propos
sur la guinée nous avons noté la
différence de ton du président entre la
lettre de félicitations adressé à
alassane ouattara et celles alpha condé
qui se contente de prendre acte d'une
situation de fait
mais ses prises de position sa compagne
telle date monsieur le ministre il ya
urgence à inciter à la mise en place
d'un réel dialogue politique dans le
pays
faute de dialogue compte tenu de la
situation quelles sanctions pourraient
être envisagées à l'encontre des
responsables de la répression de
l'exacerbation des violences
communautaires des prédations qui
conduit certains à vouloir quitter leur
lieu de vie devenue invivable
aujourd'hui on vous répondra la parole
les touristes de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères monsieur brion
monsieur le sénateur jean yves le conte
le 7 novembre dernier la cour
constitutionnelle guinéenne a confirmé
la victoire de monsieur alpha condé au
premier tour 2 dès le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle et comme vous
l'avez dit justement nous en avons pris
note en amont du processus électoral
vous l'avez rappelé la france et l'union
européenne ont exprimé à la fois leurs
interrogations sur le déroulement du
processus électoral et aussi ont
condamné les violences qui ont éclaté à
la suite de ce scrutin et à plusieurs
reprises nous avons marqué la nécessité
d'un dialogue politique interne entre
les autorités et l'opposition afin de
permettre une réconciliation de tous les
ghanéens qui mérite aujourd'hui un
climat politique apaisé
ce qui n'est pas le cas j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire moi même au
président alpha condé il ya peu de temps
lors de l'installation du président
akufo addo aac rap et le secrétaire
d'état jean baptiste lemoyne l'a rappelé
lors de l'installation et de
l'investiture d'alpha condé donc nous
estimons aussi qu'il importe de d'être
très vigilants sur le respect des droits
de l'homme et nous nous condamnons la
poursuite des détentions hors procédure
judiciaire
aux deux opposants en particulier le lot
posant monsieur diallo que vous
connaissez et pour lequel j'ai décidé
d'apporter la protection consulaire
parce que c'est un personnage qui
membres de l'opposition a été incarcéré
et est en train d'être auditionné par la
justice avec malraux dans ce temps de
graves soucis de santé il est de la
responsabilité donc de du président
conté de réunir de prendre les
initiatives nécessaires avec l'union
européenne nous avons demandé aux
autorités de guinée de faire toute la
lumière sur les événements qui se
déroulent en ce moment avec
éventuellement des mesures à prendre si
cette lumière n'est pas faite
parallèlement à cela nous voulons
néanmoins et vous le savez poursuivre
notre aide auprès de la population
guinéenne pour qu'elle ne soit pas deux
fois victime de ces comportements
merci la parole est à notre collègue
corinne imbert pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur pion au premier ministre il est
temps que vaccination rime avec
anticipation dans deux jours le vaccin
mis au point par le laboratoire
astrazeneca devraient obtenir son
autorisation de mise sur le marché
la haute autorité de santé devrait
recommander la part de la population
pour laquelle le vaccin sera indiqué et
la france devrait recevoir environ 20
millions de doses dont la livraison
serait échelonnée entre février et avril
permettant de vacciner 10 millions de
nos concitoyens en trois mois
ce vaccin présente la vôtre l'avantagé
d'avoir des conditions de conservation
classique sans difficultés de transport
si personne ne conteste la mise à
disposition des vaccins arn messager
dans les centres hospitaliers et dans
les centres de vaccination pensez vous
vous appuyez sur le circuit
pharmaceutique exemple d'aménagement du
territoire national et monsieur mise la
santé a rappelé l'intérêt du réseau
pharmaceutiques tout à l'heure pour la
distribution de ce nouveau vaccin au nom
de la transparence pouvez vous nous
confirmer le nombre de doses commandées
auprès du laboratoire astrazeneca et que
ce vaccin sera distribuée est réservé
aux circuits de la ville où est ce que
ce nombre de vaccins sera là pour
compenser des doses n'ont reçu de chez
pfizer et de chez moderna allez vous
faire confiance monsieur le ministre aux
professionnels de santé de proximité
incarné par le trio médecins infirmiers
pharmaciens trio qui est au plus près
des patients je vous remercie
au prix fort ma parole est un monsieur
solidarité de la chanter madame la
sénatrice je vous confirme mon intention
très forte de m'appuyer sur l'ensemble
du réseau de professionnels de santé en
ville et à l'hôpital pour pouvoir mener
la campagne vaccinale et j'ai indiqué
que si le vaccin risers vaccin moderna
dont les conditions de conservation et
d'utilisation avec une surveillance
médicale de 15 minutes sur place après
la vaccination ne permettait pas
d'exploiter pleinement la richesse dans
notre maillage pharmaceutique et médical
dès lors qu'un vaccin existerait qui
serait comparable finalement au vaccin
antigrippal donneront tort de nous
priver de ses ressources et de ses
compétences puisque dans la campagne
grippale nous pouvons par exemple
vacciner jusqu'à un million de personnes
par jour ça c'est un élément de réponse
madame la sénatrice maintenant j'attends
les compressions le m1 on peut pas me
reprocher de ne pas anticiper la
décision qu'une agence sanitaire
européenne n'a pas encore donné est pas
non plus d'ailleurs madame la sénatrice
me reprocher mais j'en ai l'habitude par
anticipation à la sénatrice par
anticipation c'est ça qui est le haut
je ne peux pas non plus décidé avant la
haute autorité de santé ce qu'elle va
décider dans trois ou quatre jours qui
me permettrait ensuite de prendre des
décisions vous comprenez donc je ne peux
pas aller plus vite que la musique
finalement par contre je peux vous
garantir que tous les scénarios sont sur
la table
je me suis entretenu avec la présidente
du conseil de l'ordre des pharmaciens en
voiture en venant au sénat et donc le
réseau est totalement prêt madame la
sénatrice par contre je suis plus embêté
et je le dis ici toute façon ces publics
par la capacité du laboratoire
astrazeneca tenir ses engagements en
termes de livraisons acte 1
astrazeneca nous informe qu au lieu de
recevoir trois et quatre millions de
doses respectivement en février et mars
nous recevrons 2 million et 2 millions
et demi
acte 2 que finalement les deux millions
de doses livrées au mois de février ce
sera d'abord 400 milles puis 700 milles
puis à la fin du mois un million et
quelques doses séparées pour la france
et pour toute l'europe
acte iii astrazeneca convoqué ce matin
devant des responsables de l'union
européenne a semble-t-il quitté la
réunion
ce qui n'est en général pas très bon
signe et acte iv enfin que j'ai appris
pendant votre séance de questions au
gouvernement
astrazeneca aurait communiqué sur son
incapacité de fournir davantage qu'un
tiers ou un quart des doses à
europe d'ici à la fin du premier
trimestre raison pour laquelle la
sénatrice j'étais prudent la semaine
dernière en disant que je ne suis pas
certain qu'on aurait vacciner tous les
publics fragiles avant l'été mais raison
pour laquelle je rappelle que
factuellement nous avons passé des
commandes qui engage les fabricants de
vaccins qui se sont engagés
contractuellement et consignés pour
fournir aux états les vaccins qu'ils ont
produit donc voilà ma sénatrice je suis
comme vous dans la tente des décisions à
la fois des autorités européennes et
dans la tente que l'ensemble des
laboratoires respecte les engagements
qu'ils ont pris devant la commission
européenne
je vous remercie je remercie monsieur je
ne vous fais pas de procès par
anticipation
je dis juste que par l'anticipation
réfléchissions à la distribution du
vaccin
astrazeneca dont qui ne présentera pas
ni de difficultés de transport de
logistique de difficultés de
conservation
je me réjouis que vous sachiez que vous
pensiez aux professionnels de santé pour
assurer la distribution de ce médicament
parce qu'encore une fois entre 900
centres de vaccination sur le territoire
national et 28000 21000 officines on
voit bien qu'on est au plus près des
territoires dont très bien que vous
fassiez confiance je sais bien que c'est
pas vous qui produisait des vaccins et
je sais bien qu'il ya tout c'est cette
complexité
en tout cas je souhaite que vaccination
je continue à dire qu'il faut que ça
rime avec anticipation parce que dès qu'
il faut avoir plusieurs plans en tête et
puis que cette anticipation rime avec
raison je remercie merci
la parole est à d'autres collègues
jean-michel arnaud pour le gros de
l'union centriste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues comme vous le savez
toutes et tous les communes et
intercommunalités souffre donc d aide
significative était promise elle ne sent
pas tout avoir encore été perçue par les
communes et intercommunalités la crise
sanitaire affecter lourdement les
recettes communales et intercommunales
ces dernières sont largement affectés
par l'absence d'activité c'est vrai de
toutes les communes intercommunalités
mais particulièrement de celles qui
vivent du tourisme ou de recettes
domaniales le nom quand gasnier concerne
aussi bien et cela a été dit tout à
l'heure les centres nautiques les
locations de salles polyvalentes ou
encore des gîtes et d auberge communale
100 clients dont les gestionnaires ne
peut plus assumer les charges les effets
de la crise sanitaire sur les finances
locales sont donc profond et durable
dans ces conditions madame le ministre
pouvez vous nous indiquer quand les
communes toucheront tél enfin les aides
promises pour l'achat notamment de
masques livre est commandée et payée en
2020 et également la compensation des
pertes de recettes fiscales domaniale et
tarifaires et selon quelles modalités
quel calendrier
ces dispositifs et ces aides seront
effectivement porté à nos collectivités
en attente
je vous remercie la cohésion des
territoires des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales en mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jean michel arnaud
depuis le printemps dernier le
gouvernement a pris de nombreuses
mesures pour soutenir les communes et
les intercommunalités
je rappelle très brièvement le filet de
sécurité qui vient d'être reconduit pour
2021 et en votant des dotations
supplémentaires pour les services de
transport et aussi pour les départements
vous n'en parlez pas mais je le dis au
passage dès juillet nous avons ouvert un
milliard de ce décile supplémentaires et
des garanties de recettes donc pour les
investissements en autorisant les
communes a étalé sur cinq ans
les surcoûts liés à la crise est bien
évidemment on nous avait offert au vert
des co financements pour les masquer
vous dites monsieur arnaud des
subventions ou des aides je sais plus ce
que vous avez dit promise
elles ne sont pas seulement promise
elles sont versées mais vous savez comme
moi qu'elles seront versés en deux fois
parce que vous connaissez le
fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales il ya une évaluation
d'abord et puis il faut attendre le vote
des comptes administratifs et des
comptes de gestion pour avoir des
financements d'un exercice fiscal pour
les communes et les intercommunalités
nous avons déjà versé 122 millions qui
ont été versés à titre donc d'acompte
pour compenser les pertes de recettes
communales notamment celle des taxes de
séjour de votre département et des
remontées mécaniques
ces garanties seront donc actualisé
après les comptes administratifs comme
je viens de vous le dire
70 collectivités ont choisi d'étaler des
charges qu'ovide sur plusieurs années à
notre connaissance puisqu'elle nous
l'ont fait savoir
quatorze mille cinq cents demandes de
remboursement de masques ont déjà été
honorée sur 16000 au total les autres
sont en cours d'instruction et seront
payés dans les prochaines semaines donc
comme vous le voyez et je peux vous
donner aussi sur la dessine sur le
milliard supplémentaire 560 571 millions
ont été décaissés
donc vous voyez qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
versement et par ailleurs c'est
peut-être difficile à dire parce que on
est en crise mais la situation des
communes
et beaucoup moins mauvaise que ce qu'on
imaginait avec la crise du coc vide
les chiffres sont conclure maintenant
j'ai fini monsieur le président et nous
serons toujours là pour aider les
communes si elles sont en difficulté
parce que là vous avez bénéficié du
fonds de péréquation du temps monsieur
le roch
monsieur arnaud mela le ministre je vous
remercie de ces précisions oui nous
savons que des aides ont été apportées
il n'en demeure pas moins que la
liquidation de ces êtres pose problème
dans certains départements probablement
pour dépressifs des questions comptables
auxquelles vous avez fait allusion quand
administrative pas systématiquement voté
au camp de gestion pas arrêté mais aussi
probablement parce qu'il ya certaines
difficultés avec l'administration des
finances publiques et le suivi dans le
réseau des trésoreries d'un certain
nombre de dossiers
par ailleurs monsieur le premier
ministre je crois savoir organise une
réunion avec des acteurs de la montagne
ce lundi soir il y a encore monsieur le
premier ministre des difficultés sur un
certain nombre de dispositifs je pense
par exemple à des stations de sports
d'hiver qui dispose d'un service public
industriel et commercial de gestion de
parking avec aucun client aujourd'hui et
aucune compensation à ce jour assumer
est prévue j'invite monsieur le premier
ministre a invité une délégation de
sénateurs comme nous l'avons été reçu il
ya quelques jours à l'elysée pour
pouvoir participer à ses travaux lundi
soir et le doute pas que nous serons
associés intelligemment efficacement et
dans un souci de sagesse et de
co-construction merci merci nous en
avons terminé merci monsieur le premier
ministre et dames et messieurs les
ministres avec les questions
gouvernement les prochaines questions
d'actualité ont lieu le 3 février 15h
[Musique]